dallas caico goes to the mountain you'd
love to see him go deep into this game
this is his fifth start he's 1-0 with
zra five and a half
chopper to third is it fair or foul is
the question monkada's going to throw it
on to first and that is it out so
everybody froze it was like somebody hit
the pause button the call on the field
was foul there
back to dallas he knocks it down
and one extra pitch is all that matters
kykel's 2-0 pitch that ball hit hard
down the left field line and right off
the base of the fence
in that left field corner and that'll be
extra bases for nick solac and that hop
back
continues for nick
2-2 homes swung on and missed
gallows set down on a change-up low and
outside the strike zone
[Applause]
adolesce garcia to center
his countryman robert is on it and that
will do it for the rangers in the first
the double from solak his family's happy
to sox are tuna
how about the season numbers for kyle
gibson so far he's throwing the ball
really well four starts 2.53 era
i guess it's nice to be appreciated by
your opponent
ground ball right side of the infield
solace on a slide throws out anderson
one away
the number one that this team has asked
him to do this year
what's this one hit on the ground right
to kinder philippa
and that's two up two down
and that pitch is hit on the ground a
second big high hop for solac over to
first and on three ground balls kyle
gibson is quickly out of the first
inning baseball family guy his brother
josh is a prospect in the tampa bay rays
system
we'll chop one back to kykel just like
prescribed picks it up throws it over
kykel's 2-1 is swung on it's back up the
middle tim anderson over and up with it
two out in the inning
three and two
to second base madrigal stonewalls it
another ground ball
and that's a one two three all on the
old dusty trail for dallas
one-two pitch
strikes out swinging first strike out of
the night for gibson one away
here's the pitch
swing and a miss on a slider and down
goes robert
back-to-back strikeouts for gibson here
in the bottom of the second it's a
scoreless ball game he can't throw those
pitches out of the zone
the way that he did to luis robert
dalt took a pretty big pass at this one
but
just shy of the wall and center field
and it's another one two three for
gibson who played two scoreless
well they've tried just about everything
at this point and nothing consistently
works
mercedes unloads left field a laser off
the wall
and your means scrambles around first
and he will get back it is a clothesline
single
and he takes off swinging to miss go
down to second and they
got him
pretty much straight up on the infield
not quite a swing and a miss that is
strike three
two gone
for winning the month
ground ball to short
tim anderson
and out
so abreu either got the tag down on
solac or he was out of the baseline
according to the first phase umpire
brennan miller picked it nicely and then
just floats one to first he doesn't get
a good handle on you can see it comes up
and bites him so then he's got to throw
it across jose jose does a nice job
got him on the back it appeared
that's why
it was not subject to review as joey
gallo comes up and hits one through the
shift on the right side madrigal in
shallow right tried to make a diving
stop got a glove on it but wasn't able
to stop the ball and joey gallo will get
the base hit here anyway more protecting
himself and again i don't think he was
out of the baseline anyway
that one snuck right past third base
down into that left field corner gallow
can run but they throw up the stop sign
at third
and probably wisely so
never really had a lot of power in the
bat but this is sock to second base
matter though nice pick
important pick for nick
two stranded for texas no score after
three and a half
[Music]
three two
and that one right off his thumbs
back to gibson makes for an easy play
one out in the fourth inning
and a 2-0
another ground ball that one will get
through
and the sox have a two-out single here
in the fourth two on two out louise
robert the one-two
swing and a miss and another strikeout
of robert fourth strikeout tonight for
kyle gibson
kaikel into the wind and lets it fly and
culberson lines one over third it's a
fair ball just beyond the reach of
moncada want to cut it off down the line
digging for second is culberson here's
the throw he is safe with the double to
me
it hits and then watch it
it hits once and it hits again watch
this ball watch how it bounces after it
goes over top of monkata so it hits the
ground once and then it bounces again
watch this bounce here
it takes a nasty bounce trick shot in
pool
as this to second base madrigal keeps it
near the infield and aces him at first
base
pitch home in the 2-1 it's a comebacker
to who else dallas kykel who picks it up
throws it over to first
we are officially in a pitcher's duel
oh i struck him out he came right back
with the cutter beautiful by dallas
kykel for his second strikeout no just
in
this general in the air out towards
center field and it drops in base hit
his second hit
[Applause]
of the night
on the ground
timid short has tough has the target
winning over
here's the 1-0 pitch there's a line
drive speared by a diving solac to his
right
what a play by nick solak on the infield
dirt
swing and a miss runner goes to throw
down to second
enemy oh didn't get him he just managed
to stay in there
[Applause]
yep there we go
too
first and third for robert
check to swing
no ball four
so to bring up yasmani grand dawg base
is loaded two out gibson to grandall
it gets away from trevino
scores and that may be the play that
breaks the game one nothing sucks
playoff pitch
and a swing and a miss he strikes out
grand all kinder valepa has an infield
single calhoun to second base and it's
solac
to left field on a line hamilton's up
with it they're going to wave around
calhoun to the plate
he got him
billy hamilton cuts down willie calhoun
and the white sox hold on to a 1-0 inch
[Applause]
on the ground bummer's got it tim covers
double clutch who cares double play
liam hendricks comes on with no margin
for error with a one-run lead here and
looks like the rain is starting to fall
[Music]
[Applause]
struck him out
here's calhoun one for three is single
one pitch left it up calhoun hits it
hard out to center field that one is
gone
and calhoun is tied in the ninth look
how high up
willie goes to get this pitch
[Applause]
robert left-hand side pass hold tipped
off his glove luis thinking about two
and he breaks it down it'll bring up
nick madrigal with two out in the inning
oh and two
nick to right on a line oh
2-1 final score
nikki two strikes
gives the sox the win